[Musique]
pour terminer c'est le moment de
retrouver le coup de coeur culture de la
semaine avec mélanie pokémon soir sa
quarante ans de scène et toujours autant
d'engagement le groupe trust est de
retour sur scène mélanie poker ou les
écouter attrape tout simplement le
groupe mythique de rock joue samedi soir
le 24 novembre à la merise après 50 pose
de séparation plus précisément le groupe
se reforme en 2005 dans 2016
les cinq membres donnent le ton de leur
tournée au nom de la rage tour
l'occasion aussi de découvrir leur
nouvel album le 10e dans le même sens
sorti cette année treize titres alors à
leur style fidèles oui surprennent avec
une reprise notamment de je m'en fous
pas mal une certaine dit caf et ses
rebelles d' antisociale sont ils
toujours aussi rebelle anti sociale
difficile de parler de traces de sang
mentionné ce titre leur titre
pourrait-on même dire sorti en 1980 est
toujours d'actualité mais oui bernie
bonvoisin et norbert nono krief
s'inspire toujours de cette actualité
ils sont toujours rebelle et le nous
dévorer c'est de se faire une idée
[Musique]
merci
et dire tout
les jambes
[Musique]
trust est en tournée depuis 2016 et donc
pour leurs 40 ans une scène francilienne
celle de la merise à trappes
c'est le samedi 24 novembre à 20h30 et
je ne sais pas vous grégory mais je ne
résiste pas à conclure ce coup de coeur
avec leurs titres un antisocial
[Musique]
désormais au service
non
je sais ça
tous
oui
[Musique]
merci mélanie et votre émission le 7-8
culture est à retrouver dans un instant
ce